bonjour prise on t'as demandé de
sélectionner témoin au culte de
télévision à toi et tu as voulu ravoir
un moment culte c'est en 2003 sur france
2 pendant les championnats du monde
d'athlétisme
tu allé à la rencontre de l'athlète
mélina robert michon spécialiste de
lancer disque ça c'était une grosse
rigolade regarde mes mains je signale
des oh lalalalalalalalala nécessaire et
ses balles et vous je vais chercher
l'essai boum c'est vous oh là là là
c'est beau sa surface
qu'est ce que ces gens là son statut à
sa juste ça c'est trop grave ouah ah
ouais ouais ouais bah ouais t'as
vraiment 705 studio tu deviens le tu
deviens le disque du temps voilà je vais
discuter un peu
lundi c'est un peu comme la flèche de
khalid gimone tu vois c'est à dire que
là où la flèche va ton esprit et ceux
des transports c'est fou ça aux autres
outre rigolade complètement ouf c'est en
août 2010 est une journaliste de bfm tv
temple un duplex spécial canicule depuis
avignon alors tu décides de tincques
rust et dans le décor tu étais assis tu
étais tout en détente les pieds dans une
fontaine en fait c'est pas du tout
préparé c'est juste magique la meuf un
duplex et à francis lalanne qui passe
par là il y bien regarder on vous
olympique et en particulier en paca où
36 degrés est presque un minimum
judas van aelst vous êtes à avignon pour
pour bfm tv le plan canicule exactement
à la préfecture du vaucluse qui a
déclenché hier le plan alerte canicule
niveau 3 il fait très chaud ici à
avignon 1 38 degrés
ces personnes de plus par jour des
personnes âgées qui vivent à domicile
qui peut alors se rendre quelques heures
dans ces établissements pour se
rafraîchir alors l agence régionale de
santé la doit à ses recommandations aux
habitants du vaucluse mentalement moi je
ne sais pas que je suis dans l'image non
maintenant je te jure c'est mon coin
c'est mon coin ouais c'est mon coin
avignon après les représentations
j'allais me détendre lâche et quand je
vois arriver d une équipe de bfm jordi
vous partez de là c'est mon coin
vous allez assez grand avignon vous
venez pas film est juste un mot c'est
mon moment à moi donc vous dégagez donc
je leur demande gentiment je ne dis pas
comme ça et ils me disent auteurs vous
promets chier je ne veux pas être
il voulait dans l'image non je ne veux
pas dans l'image vous mettez plus loin
plus loin moi je vous me laisser
tranquille fait ou pas du tout je suis
fils mais tu as voulu revoir aussi un
autre moment qu'on a vécu ensemble
kita apparemment beaucoup marqué puisque
tu m'en parlait tout à l'heure en 2003
je te recevait sur le morning live et
tout d'un coup tu appelles chaud francis
lalanne puisqu'il y avait francis
lalanne après francis la laine
je crois que dans l'union mais dévoile
au pognon et la foi et vie est bien plus
jolie cave aux ivoire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ça c est tres me rappelais plus facile
mais pas non plus mais il faut quand
même dire aux autres il était 7 heures
du matin on embrasse ariane qui est avec
vous nos brassards hier et ça c'était la
seule émission que j'avais accepté de
faire après 60 jours 60 c'est vrai
passionné
voilà c'est un entonnoir honda fait
rigoler j'ai fait que rire ma mère tu le
vois d'ailleurs ce que des francis
dhalleine un mec qui mangeaient de
l'oignon stefan meierhans voir aussi
cette séquence culte ça c'est des gens
qui ont demandé quand ils ont su
courseulles et francis lalanne s'est
bien sûr leur avis de recherche
ta célèbre tirade contre les
ronds-de-cuir encore soupirail qatariens
tu veux pas la voir
c'est incroyable ça fait combien ça fait
30 ans 28 génial ça fait 30 ans a cédé
dès qu'on a envie de recoller alors
vas-y non l inverse 6 me gloria ont bien
plus des moments de télé lance alors non
pas parce qu'en plus c'est des moments
vrais cost et zaoui j'étais tellement
bouleversée à ce moment là que
franchement d'être je ne savais même
plus où j'étais là c'est pourquoi on
leur passe parce que des moments comme
ça il y en a plus qu'assez des moments
de vérité en fait les regarder mais je
voudrais bien triste que on à la télé
que nous on voulait que cet opéra sorte
je vais arriver à parler je vais arriver
à dire deux mots
jeu derrière les théâtres derrière l'été
at on en paye des impôts on paie des
trucs qui derrière les théâtres il ya
des gens qui dirigent des théâtres les
opéras tout ça oui la caméra vous allez
la caméra on est là voilà tous les ronds
de cuir tout vous rond de cuir qu'être
derrière vos opéra derrière vos bureaux
à dépenser le fric des gens voilà il n'y
a pas que moi il ya plein de jeunes
compositeurs comme moi qui sont pas
morts qu'ils sont vivants etc ont besoin
d'endroits pour qu'on joue leur musique
et vous vous n'êtes même pas capable de
la lire
et eux ils l'ont écrite alors les
empêcher plus les empêchait plus de
jouer leur musique
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bon je t'ai micro il est incroyable
bernard qu'est ce que tu as à dire là
dessus je dis qu'on peut que s'incliner
devant la sincérité et la vérité mais
oui on ne peut que s'incliner comme dire
l'amadouer si ce n'est pas demandé de
sélectionner des moments de télé culte
préféré et a voulu revoir un moment
c'était dans à prendre ou à laisser sur
tf1 est une candidate elle était plus
motivé de rencontrer arthur que pour
gagner le jeu regarde comment ça va bien
sûr à dieu je vous ai fait des
cochonneries reçoit oui plein qu'est ce
que vous avez fait un geste
vous avez de quoi vous avez fait quoi
comme rêve je peux pas ainsi une mine ou
à un petit bout du rêve
non parce qu'après vous allez le
regretter non mais dites moi je n'ai
rien à regretter j'ai rêvé de votre mère
est arrivée deux mois tout nu
et alors alors ça s'est très bien passé
est ce que comme dans les chansons les
draps s'en souviennent encore oui
c'est bien mouillé magique non mais je
trouve qu'il est super touchant arthur
c'est un gars que j'ai appris à
connaître et apprécier j'ai fait une
aventure avec lui qui s'appelait 60
jours 60 nuits et moi je les aime bien
voilà tu as voulu aussi revoir un grand
moment de télé c'était sur le plateau du
millionnaire en 97
philippe risoli recevait marque un
candidat digne d'une caméra cachée
satiété énorme c'est francis qui a
choisi ça regarde sur le plateau du
millionnaire et qui peut-être bonjour ma
je vais vous donner des définitions mais
sérieuse mais il faut trouver l'injure
correspondante
on essaye au moins sont comme ça les
résultats
[Rires]
pas question de s'amuser on y va c'est
en fait en moins de profits
je vous dis ouverture cadre angulaire
pratiqué dans la muraille des vaisseaux
de guerre et c'est un point de passage à
la bouche des canaux c'est un trou puis
c'est tout
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
il est très nerveux il est très nerveux
la séquence préférée de francis elle est
complètement folle c'était durant un
micro trottoir pour la télé néerlandaise
un couple devaient chacun son tour
répondre à des questions coquines pour
remporter un séjour à paris et regardez
la réponse de la femme à la fin c'est
magique c'est parti la maîtrise est
nouveau
[Rires]
mais tu n'y es pas
écoutez vaucluse et même pas
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
imerys décompresser excepté je suis
presque envie de la voir
on a envie de la revoir parce que
regarder ne fera pas mieux que ça on
n'aura pas de succès j'aimerais bien
quand tu vois pas 30 ans de délai si
jamais vous dis regardez rigoureux de la
mairie n va
[Rires]
mais si elle va
click'n'rock les x témoin et impôts
[Applaudissements]
c'est génial
françois loos exceptionnel
extraordinaire mais ça c'est pas parce
que il ya lui dans un moment de
sidération elle elle peut pas révéler sa
et lui dont il ya chérie je les dis ça
va week-end à paris le pire c'est que la
veuve a pas dû faire et non ce qui est
surtout intéressant c'est ce que chacun
a retenu du rapport c'est vrai la
cuisine mais bien de mars et la femme
est bien de vénus bah ouais tu ça rime
avec confucius